peck lui le piratage de cd qui prend
vous être constaté une envergure
mondiale
oui cet après midi le tribunal de
saint-etienne doit statuer sur une
éventuelle condamnation de deux jeunes
pirates qui permettait la reproduction
de céder grâce au réseau internet c'est
une méthode qui pose d'énormes problèmes
à l'industrie du disque et cela d'autant
plus qu'elle est facilement accessible
reportage de frédéric dupuis avec raimu
poissonnier
dans un chambre nicolas écoutent de la
musique en toute illégalité
alors ça c'est un cd gravé des meilleurs
morceaux de francis cabrel
ça vient d'internet qualité cd gratuit
juste au téléphone à payer et si rigal
c'est censé être légale illégale car
nicolas court circuite les maisons de
disques ne verse pas un centime aux
producteurs ni au compositeur bref son
disque ne lui coûte rien ou presque
grâce à internet
nicolas n'est pas un pirate génie de
l'informatique juste un internaute fan
de musique qui ses cliques et où il faut
actuellement on a plus de 45000 chansons
disponibles
je tape le nom de l'artiste le titre
d'une de ses chansons pour choix ensuite
je lance la recherche
alors donc l'âge et les résultats de la
recherche sur francis cabrel
alors je peux choisir n'importe laquelle
donc je lance aux téléchargements treize
minutes plus tard la chanson est en
mémoire dans son ordinateur
elle provient de la discothèque d'un
autre internaute ici on s'échange les
chansons à l'échelle planétaire grâce au
système mp3 les sites les plus demandés
sur le web
en clair la musique est compressé par un
logiciel pour passer par internet
ensuite il ne reste plus qu'à la graver
sur un cd up sera boîte
en fait moi avant j'allais à la fnac
avec avec un portefeuille plein de
billets maintenant j'y vais avec un
papier un crayon pour noter les titres
parce que je m'y perds un peu tout ce
qui sort en ce moment ça m'aide un peu
pour vous mon téléchargement un jeu
d'enfant pratiquement sans risque pour
lui qui n'est pas du goût de tout le
monde ici dans cette société qui
s'occupe de la protection des droits
d'auteur on traque les adresses qui
proposent de tels produits
une fois identifié les propriétaires de
sites sont avertis ou assignés en
justice car c'est la survie des artistes
et de l'industrie du disque qui est en
jeu l'idée ce serait de sensibiliser le
plus large public possible à ce problème
3 la musique ça n'est pas gratuit ça
nécessite des investissements
considérables
les artistes qui avertissent leur temps
de travail et tout
création attendent en contrepartie
d'avoir une juste rémunération
nicolas lui pense que les céder dans le
commerce sont trop chers alors il n'a
aucun remords
et ironie de l'histoire les seuls
disques qu'ils achètent encore ce sont
ses vinyles dont le désuet craquements
n'est pas disponible sur le net